la reserva federal aumenta sus tasas de
interés de referencia por primera vez
desde el 2018 el banco central
estadounidense sube del 0% ál 0 25% las
tasas de interés con esta movida el
presidente bailén intenta reducir así la
inflación anual acumulada que fue del 79
por ciento en febrero y es que en el
futuro cercano la invasión a ocular y
los eventos relacionados a ésta
posiblemente aumenten la presión
inflacionaria así lo dijo yo ron pavo
director de la fe hay que resaltar que
la crisis en la cadena de suministro los
altos precios del petróleo derivados de
las sanciones a rusia la alta demanda y
los grandes paquetes de gasto público
que el gobierno inyectó en la economía
son algunos de los factores que han
ayudado a aumentar esta inflación récord
que vive eeuu tras su reunión trimestral
el banco central también proyecto que
espera una tasa de interés finalizando
el año de 1 9% antes de elevarla al 2,8
por ciento en el 2023 sin embargo la fed
también podría aumentar las tasas más
rápidos y la inflación que debería en la
imagen de 2 % no se controla al banco
central le quedan 6 reuniones este año y
la próxima está programada para el 3 y
el 4 de mayo